So any questions before we start today?
I think from the last class,
maybe I'll do a short recap of what we
were discussing in the previous session.
If something needs discussion,
we'll take that up separately.
So we started with understanding what AI
models are, what exactly a model means,
and what are the features it does.
We saw what are the capabilities,
the core.
pillars which is being there in every AI.
So reasoning,
perception starts with and learning.
So these two have been there for quite
some time, right? You understand,
you perceive the information,
you understand from what is available.
and you translate into meaningful
representation.
So that has been there quite some time.
But what is expanding in that area is
earlier it was perceiving more only from
text and images.
Now it is trying to perceive.
More from the.
Vision, audio, speech processing, etc.
Right?
So can we get this PPT before we start?
Okay, so we can follow along. Yeah,
that should be fine.
Just give me a second,
I will upload this PPT.
To the TEAMS folder.
Upload it to the team shared document.
Whatever I put in the deal on page,
I will do it after the class.
Maybe if there are certain things which
are missed out, we can.
Yeah.
So I was talking about perception.
So that is where it is expanding.
So perception and learning were the base
which it started, right?
So learning has supervised learning,
unsupervised learning,
all that has been expanded in terms of
how they understand the patterns and how
they look at the statistical information
which is hidden in the data.
and reinforcement learning,
how they can learn from their predicted
correct outputs and incorrect,
how they can be penalized based on the
incorrect output.
And that's the learning changes.
Reasoning and acting, problem solving.
So reasoning,
is the ability to connect,
apply the logic and then act upon it,
right?
So reasoning is very important and we see
the language models becoming more
reasoning models.
and they are improving.
So the advanced reasoning is what we are
having today.
So we are looking at earlier also there
were basic reasoning,
but now we are getting into advanced
reasoning techniques so that we solve the
system to thinking chain of thought.
So how the...
prompting the model to break down the
complex query into smaller steps in
step-by-step approach.
And also evaluating multiple potential
paths.
Train of thought is one single linear
chain, but there can be multiple changes.
If this is the case,
and that it can diverge into two
different outcomes.
So, branching can happen, right? So,
so reasoning models are getting advanced,
and of course, acting on it,
reasoning and acting,
that that's what is more important, right?
So, how do agents plan?
divide them into task and then execute it
and then they have to replan if a step
fails.
All that is what problem solving and the
agents are basically...
Something built on top of the large
language models is working towards that,
so we started with that in the previous
session.
on fundamentals to AI.
And then we looked at the evolution of AI
also parallelly,
how it was started with role-based
systems, expert system,
then moved to machine learning,
deep learning models,
and then more reasoning models,
large language models,
and then reasoning models.
and how they are becoming more autonomous
in nature with agentic planning, etc.
So today we will continue,
as mentioned yesterday,
we have somewhat have an idea on the
landscape,
but there are a few other important
things we need to get into a little more
in detail because it's highly necessary.
There are a lot of other things in AI.
When it comes to a model like fine tuning,
how do you tune a parameter, all that,
that is not our requirement.
Now we have a model.
So what are the difference between ML
engineering and AI engineering is in ML
engineering, we get into the model,
we try to...
optimize the model,
we try to work with the model,
we try to tune the parameters. But here,
in this particular course,
or anything related with building an
application around the AI or using AI to
build an application,
we are using the model,
but it is necessary for us to have an
understanding how the model is
Um...
working so that we are able to utilize it
to the full capability,
plus we are able to rely on it,
make it more reliable,
and how do we tackle the probabilistic
nature, etc.
That is what is our understanding.
So that is where we are heading towards
to.
So in that development cycle,
we need to understand tokenization in a
little more in detail.
So that's why I will spend some time
today on the AI tokens,
basically how the tokens are getting
built.
Except, uh,
how they how the tokenization works,
etcetera.
So I think many of you would have tried
this platform, Open AI Tokenizer.
So what did you all observe when you
tried to?
Say something.
I paste the link on me.
So they want to try.
There is one more leak also which I have
pasted it and I think it worked somewhere.
Hugging face also has one tokenizer which
can you can try with both.
What else?
Try that also.
Okay,
so anything interesting observation when
you've tried?
So, open AI or this one.
Okay,
so you saw that as the newer models are
coming in,
the number of tokens are comparatively
less, right?
OK, for the same sentence,
the newer models are trying to give you
lesser number of tokens.
Right.
Yeah.
Okay,
so all of you tried with the only English.
Did any of you try with other languages
or probably anyone tried with code?
Anyone who tried other languages?
Okay, if not, try it now. Okay,
try it after some time or today.
So you'll see,
you'll be able to understand the
difference. So in AI,
a token is the basic unit of a language
model.
And it can be a simple character,
it can be a part of a word,
or it can be a word,
depending on the model. Right?
So if you see here in this example,
the picture below is from GPT-4. So
It I is 1 token, can is 1 token,
and apostrophe T is another token,
weight is 1 token,
to build a awesome AI applications is
another token,
so 9 tokens totally are there.
So, here,
if you see the word can't is broken into
two tokens, can and a positive.
And you can see different models do it
differently.
So this process of breaking the original
text into token is what is called as
tokenization. Now,
this word tokenization is itself,
you have to be very careful.
That's why I've added AI yesterday.
I was just written only tokenization,
but then I realized.
the whole Web 3 cryptocurrency,
their tokenization.
There are so many things on tokenization.
right? So there are non-fungible tokens,
there is a Bitcoin token.
So there are many things on tokenization.
So the word tokenization,
if you directly put,
it might give you different context.
So that is why I prefixed it with AI.
So whenever we talk about tokenization,
here in this course,
it is related to the tokens.
The LLMs are dealing with,
and the grounds we are dealing with,
so you have to be careful when you are
actually asking that, so now...
The process of breaking is what is
happening, right?
And there are different tokenizers,
different methods in which the
tokenization happens,
and if you take a GPT-4,
the average token is approximately
three-fourth length of the word, or...
It says like approximately 4 characters
comes under one word.
So what exactly is a token is the set of
all.
tokens a model can work with is the one,
it's called the model's vocabulary.
And you can use a smaller number of
tokens to construct a larger number of
words, right? You can use the token, so,
for example...
brightness, darkness.
You take those two words. OK, in a token,
if you take them as words,
brightness and darkness is only two words.
So,
but a token will split bright and nest
separately, dark and nest separately.
So nest will become one token.
And the bright and dark will be one token,
so now with this commonly applied,
it might.
further understand or use it to identify
the relationship between words, etc.
at a later point in time. Right,
so how does this tokenization happen in
general? Yes.
Tokens are nothing but fragments of.
the input text we give, right?
So 4 characters of English test or 100
tokens roughly translate to 75 words.
That is around how the tokens look like,
right?
So the short common words are put up as a
single token and longer words are broken
down into.
multiple tokens and the spaces,
punctuations, line break,
all of them are also tokens.
Right, so...
When deep learning models were trained on
vast quantities of unstructured,
unlabeled data, they become the...
foundation models, right?
So this LLM or foundation models were
trained basically on text.
So they were trained on a process called
fine tuning,
which has a lot of unstructured text.
So they learned the relationship.
between sentences, words,
even portions of the words.
And then they extract knowledge from this,
so when an LLM is fed input,
the first thing it does is to break it
into tokens, and next step is...
Each token is...
fed into is assigned a numerical
identifier,
which is fed back into the LLNs for
processing, etc.
And then it starts identifying the
semantic similarity between the two words,
the two tokens.
and the generates responses based on the
patterns it learns, etc.
So now,
when you say it's not only for text,
when I say tokens, it's not just for text.
Tokens can also be for other multimodal
aspects, right? So...
The tokens which are for the other
categories, right?
Audio models are converted into
spectrograms that are then tokenized.
Images have tokens in form of pixel.
And other models,
if they have other modality,
whatever is there,
they also come under the token.
OK, so large language models, if you take,
they are basically basically text-based
in initial days,
so they start with that now.
Why tokens?
That is the question which will come to
us directly,
like before AI or before a few.
Years or a decade back when we want to
process a text or when we want to
actually understand natural language,
we were dividing the.
Text in two words.
Right,
we were dividing the sentence into words
and trying to find a number of
occurrences of each words,
and we were trying to identify the
relationship between the context,
so that that's how it was.
Right,
so now why that word is not used or not
character is used here, right?
Why do language models use token as their
unit instead of word and the character?
So there are three reasons. Of course,
there can be multiple reasons,
and there are methods for word
tokenization and character tokenization,
which are still useful in some places.
I will come to that. But generally,
LLMs use tokens as their unit instead of
words or character.
Right,
so the first reason is when you pick
characters.
They don't,
when you break them into characters,
it doesn't give you a meaningful
component out of it. And it is too.
Right, so it is very difficult. That is,
tokens allow the model to break the words
into more meaningful components.
So when I say cooking,
cook can and ING can be broken.
and with both parts of the word carrying
some meaning.
And when you take tokens,
when compared with words,
there are fewer unique tokens than words.
For example, I said about brightness,
darkness, or cooking, dancing, etc.
All these ING,
this is still a unique token.
But when you say words, dance is a word,
dancing is a word.
Cook is a word, cooking is a word.
So the unique words,
the vocabulary is very high, right?
So there are fewer unique tokens compared
to the unique words,
and this helps us to reduce the
vocabulary's overall size,
making the model much better and
efficient.
So, that's the second reason.
The third is tokens also help the model
process unknown words.
Like, for example, Googling, right?
Googling is or ChatGPT is not a word
which we have we might have in our
dictionary or vocabulary, so,
but if this kind of a token system is
followed, it can divide.
Google and ING into.
Different.
tokens,
ChatGPT and ING into different tokens and
it could help the model understand its
structure. So tokens have a balance,
have fewer units than words,
while retaining more meaningful,
more meaning than words.
what individual words or individual
characters will maintain.
So that was the basic idea why
tokenization is something which is.
Encouraged or it is being used in all
LLMs predominantly,
which really works with a large amount of
data.
OK, so now having said that,
are there no tokens which are?
word-based or character-based
tokenization methods. There are methods,
tokenization methods,
which are based on words, characters, etc.
, which we are going to discuss shortly.
Okay,
Shrey says that he tried with Japanese.
Like is based on the prompt will be like
tokens I didn't understand Anantha
Krishna's question.
Yes,
if your question is whether our input
prompts will be broken down into tokens,
yes, that is what it will happen.
So the input prompt is broken down into
tokens,
and each of the token is given a
numerical identifier that it goes into
the embedding process.
That is the next step in the LLM.
So that is where it will start predicting
the most probable next word for that
particular answer, and it will generate.
So it will have input prompt is also
divided into tokens.
Whatever comes as a response also,
The tokens,
it is considered as tokens only.
So the response,
the number of tokens generated in the
output, that is also.
Treated as a token.
We'll explore more on that shortly.
Okay, I tried the weird word. Okay,
so 9 tokens. Okay, maybe ION, CAT,
and all are familiar repetitions, I think.
So that is why you would have had only 9
tokens.
Okay, so yeah, okay,
simplification itself is treated as one
character. That's nice.
It's interesting.
Did this change for other model?
Was it same for all the models?
Not tried, almost same, ma'am.
No, no, the last part I'm asking,
the so Cation, if FICATIO,
GB T3.
the entire thing is 1 token, right?
So was it the same in other models also?
A number of Philippines.
Yes,
tokens and characters are the count is
Thank you.
same also last like ification that is
what is getting taken as one token.
Okay, okay.
So then there's something interesting
about that entire word.
Probably it's more frequently occurring
or in the vocabulary or something like
that, right? Yeah, that's interesting.
Okay,
so now what are the other tokenization
techniques?
Though they are not practically in use,
we will look at some of the other
tokenization techniques.
Okay,
so the largest word has 17 tokens in
GPT-4 and 15 tokens in GPT-5.
That's great.
Okay,
so how does this tokenization happen,
right?
So we look at a few tokenization
techniques.
Though we are concerned only about the
subword tokenization which is being
followed,
that is the technique which is used in
all LNS.
We quickly look through the other
tokenization techniques also just to have
an understanding.
So, there are these techniques.
are used in different LNMs.
So word tokenization basically is the one
which...
Splits into individual words or word-like
units,
and each word becomes a separate token.
And word tokenization.
The problem with word tokenization is it
might struggle with contractions or
compound words. It might have a problem.
So a dictionary maps every distinct word
in a language, right?
So every single word in a language will
have a single ID.
That is how word tokenization works.
So if I say the software engineer is
reading a book, something like that,
each of the word is a separate token.
The software engineer is reading a book.
So everything will be a separate word.
The basic strength of this word
tokenization is it's simple to understand
and it actually has a good boundaries
related to natural world because that is
what we use.
But the weakness when you look at it,
it can easily go out of vocabulary issue
because it's, as I said,
there are many new words will be added.
We have to keep training or improving the
dictionary or there can be many
unoptimized,
unknown words which are present.
For example,
Dictionary might not have,
if you look at an English as a language,
it might not, I don't know whether.
Words like ChatGPT or Kubernetes,
et cetera, would have been added, right?
Still,
we when we write certain words in a word
or something, we get spell check errors,
et cetera,
because they are not part of the
dictionary yet,
so the system when you use such word
tokenization.
the system will mark them as unknown
words,
which will lose the semantic meaning of
their presence itself.
So that is 1 main weakness with word
organization. And of course,
the vocabulary explodes, right?
There are multiple languages and each
language has millions of words.
Different typos for the same words,
so every supporting every word requires a
massive lookup table.
and it blows up the memory usage as well.
So that is the problem.
And words like the can't in our previous
example, right? C-A-N, apostrophe T,
or don't, et cetera,
they are not compound words, right?
They don't get splitted in a right way.
Sometimes it's splitted.
KHAN and team.
by compound words, sometimes,
say for example, database,
database might be separated.
So data and base are completely
irrelevant when it talks about the single
word database.
So there are a few problems when it comes
to.
word tokenization,
which basically splits based only on
white space or punctuations, etc.
Then there is character tokenization,
which makes each character in the text a
separate token.
So this is the default one which we have
been using
This tokenization method is what we have
been using in our programming languages
whenever we want to process strings and
characters, etc., right?
So the method works well when dealing
with languages.
Um...
Or which don't have clear word boundaries,
or basically when you are dealing with
handwritten recognition,
so when you go for...
high sequence words or when you want to
have application for handwriting
recognition or something like that,
then this character tokenization is
rectified.
But generally for a text in digital word,
we might not
be able to use it in a full required way.
So, but it's very simple.
The vocabulary will be very simple.
It consists of base alphabets, digits,
and all the basic symbols.
So the number of items will be less.
The model can pass any word, any typo.
And it's everything from the basic
characters only. It's a small vocabulary,
so only minimal memory can be used for
the token storage.
And it is perfect for continuous
languages without spaces,
especially Chinese, Japanese,
or wherever you have handwritten
recognition, et cetera. It's very easy.
But the downside is...
Think of words like examples we have got
in chat,
one which Abhinav and Shreya mentioned,
sorry, not Shreya, Shreya mentioned.
So these words will be into 15, 20 token,
the largest word,
I don't know how many characters it has,
but it will be into such individual
tokens which can.
End up in a high sequence length, right?
So this will fill up the model's context
window easily,
and the computational power,
or the computation will also scale
exponentially, right?
So that is the problem.
And the model must spend,
apart from the memory being very high,
because you are going to split it into
character-wise.
In order to understand the semantic
meaning of it also,
how to construct words from the letters
can also take a significant amount of
time.
So you are also losing the semantics
within the input prompt.
and you will have to reconstruct that
again. So it is again reworked, right?
So that is why character tokenization
doesn't fit well for LLMs or the real
world applications apart from base
applications like handwriting,
recognition, etc. So the third type,
the subword tokenization,
That is what is being used by most of the
systems today.
They break down less frequently used
words into units of frequently occurring
sequences of character.
So subword tokens are bigger than
individual characters.
but smaller than the entire word itself.
So by breaking the words also into
subword tokens,
a model can handle words better.
which were not present in the training
data, it can handle them better.
So a name,
I didn't mention the name actually,
so byte pad encoding or BPE.
So that is the one of the famous.
Tokenization algorithm,
somewhat tokenization algorithm,
just for your reference,
I'm just typing it.
So basically.
Byte pair encoding is 1 algorithm;
it starts with a vocabulary of characters
on words and merges them into tokens,
which most often appear together. So,
this is the most standard used by almost
all code and text-based elements we have.
today.
So it dynamically balances between the
vocabulary size as well as the sequence
length.
So you have character tokenization and
you have the word tokenization.
Something in between which gets best out
of the both word words is the subword
tokenization.
So it brings up a good balance while
breaking rare words into commonly used
subword chunks.
So how does this byte pair encoding work
is? It starts with the base vocabulary,
which is based on which it is trained
with of base characters.
It count character pairs frequencies
across millions of documents.
It will have it. Iteratively,
it will merge the most frequently
adjacent pairs into the new tokens.
And that could have been the reason why,
though the last
Six, 7, 8,
9 characters together in Abhinav's
example,
defecation has come up as a single token
because it might be one of the most
frequently occurring set of characters
together, right?
So,
it iteratively merges the most frequently
adjacent pairs into new token,
and it stops when the target vocabulary
size is reached, right? So,
it keeps on dividing.
And it doesn't go until characters.
So it, it, and that is it, it works.
It sees four or five characters together
frequently occur once it chunks and it
stops, then the target vocabulary size,
that is how many tokens can come out on
that, it stops there.
So, common words.
Though they are bigger in length,
for example, engineer, et cetera,
will still be a single token itself.
Though they are word based,
it still can be a single token inside a
subword tokenization. And ran words,
technical words, for example,
microservices.
Micro and services,
micro services together is not a very
common word,
but micro and services are common,
so it might be into two sub word tokens
also.
Okay,
and how does it deal when you have a
spelling mistakes or errors, typo errors,
or unseen words?
It will do again based on the frequently
occurring words,
what part of the word it sees as together.
That will be the sub.
Subword token,
and then the remaining will be the other
subword token. So,
the strength with the subword
tokenization is it handles the out of
vocabulary very gracefully by falling
back to smaller subwords or individual
characters, and the context.
is efficiently used. So common words,
even though they are big,
they are still under one token,
keeping a check on the sequence length
and keeping manageable sequence length.
So that is the major strength and why it
is being used, the balance it maintains.
Between the vocabulary size and the
sequence length,
by treating them is what actually makes
it the strength of this subword
tokenization, weakness again.
When it comes to grammar rules,
or you want a more linguistic one, right?
So, non-semantic splits will be high here,
so if you look at the algorithm VP itself.
It will use statistical frequency,
the common words which are occurring
together.
It will count character pair frequency
across millions of documents based on
which it is trained,
and it will split them.
It doesn't understand anything based on
the grammar rules or etc.
So a token split might occur at an
arbitrary boundary.
rather than a logical linguistic one also,
right? So that is what is the problem.
And this subword tokenization initially,
the next topic I'm going to talk about is
how it will not seamlessly work for code
base.
There are a lot of things we have to do
to improve it for the code base itself.
So that is our next topic.
So though it works well for the text and
the natural language,
it doesn't work well with code base,
et cetera. So we cannot use it as such.
With code, et cetera, right?
And the last one,
the morphological tokenization uses
morphemes,
which are nothing but individual words or
parts of words that carry specific
meanings or grammatical functions.
So, in in a language,
we have something called as a prefix
suffix.
and the road toward, right? So when I say,
Incompetence.
In is a competent is the word,
and in is a prefix indicating a negation.
Competent is the root word and ends is a
suffix indicating the quality or the
state, the current state.
So any tokenization which are.
divides the input based on the morphemes
or the language prefix, suffix,
and the root.
That is what is called as morphological
tokenization.
Each morpheme becomes a token which
enables LLM to handle.
grammatical structures very well and this
is quite used in linguistic accurate text
if you want to generate,
understand grammatical structures,
handle word variations, etc.
So the smallest unit of language is the
morphemes. So we have prefix,
root and suffix.
So instead of statistically merging a
linguistic parser,
this morphological tokenization is a
linguistic parser.
which breaks words down based on
structural grammar rules.
Okay, so.
Implemented, implement, ed is separate,
right?
Implement is the root work and ed is the
suffix, meaning it is fast tense,
the state where it is.
If I say unimplemented,
then we are negating the action or
reversing the action.
So prefix, suffix, and the root, right?
So the strength of this morphological one
is it can generalize for the model itself,
can generalize for grammatical rules
across the words.
And if the model knows very well what
unrepresents in an unimplemented,
Right,
it can immediately infer what does when
attached to a new root word,
like untested or etcetera, right? So,
that is where linguistic precision is the
strength of such tokenization technique,
and...
Especially other languages, right?
I'm not familiar with many other
languages,
so I'm not able to comment on that.
But languages where they say are highly
inflected,
that is a language where words change
their forms by adding suffixes, prefixes,
or internal vowels to show grammatical
relationships.
like gender, tense, etc.
So example is Hindi, Marathi, German,
all these languages, they have a lot,
they are called as highly inflected
languages. Okay.
I'm not very familiar to give you an
example, but maybe you can.
Read out,
so these languages have a complex ending
changes,
like English is a weakly inflected
language.
Highly inflected languages rely on
complex ending changes on their prefix
and suffix.
added to a word changes their form itself,
right? So for example,
when I say cat to cats, yes,
does only change it from a plural to a
singular,
but that in another language might change
the entire meaning of it.
So that's what is an highly inflected.
Language and.
This particular morphological
tokenization,
when it works with inflected language,
it has a high performance that words
change form radically based on tense and
cases, etc. The downside, if you consider,
it requires
to an understanding of the language
specific linguistic rules and parsers,
training them is not that easy.
And it might have a lot of synthetic
inputs, unstructured data, mixed language,
because nowhere the language is pure,
right,
even in English or take any language.
we have to be.
All of them are not pure in itself.
There are many mistakes which are
happening and they will get trained based
on that data only.
So their formal morphological rules will
fall apart and it's practically not
possible for any individual or any group
of individuals
to write out all the linguistic rules or
parsers practically.
So that is what about the four.
Tokenization techniques and the type of
tokenization used depends on.
what the model needs to accomplish, right?
So different organization methods can be
used for various applications or various
LLMs based on what they are constructed
for. Also,
different organization methods can also
be used in a hybrid fashion or in a
combined way to achieve certain required
results. So each LLM
can go and modify the way in which they
tokenize, et cetera.
So that's on the techniques.
Now we look at an example.
So all of us used words and sentences,
complex words,
and different languages to test.
Now when it comes to code,
that is what we are more inclined to,
right? We are going to.
Our LLMs should understand the source
codes,
and they have come with a separate syntax.
The working in the software industry or
learning programming from scratch,
we know that what a semi colon means,
sort of a.
bracket is open, it has to be closed.
What is a parentheses, etc.
But how does models treat code?
That is what is something which we need
our understanding, right? So now,
Most modern LLMs use the subword
tokenization, so if you do a sentence.
We saw how it works, but here,
instead of a sentence, I'm giving up.
Piece of line of code.
Right, the definition of a function,
right? So, def,
so this is how it divides the model. So,
def is treated as one, calculate as one,
then under score is treated as a separate
one, sum.
Then we have.
Parenthesis and A as one token,
this comma as one, and then B,
and the close brace parenthesis and the...
colon as one token.
So this is how the token gets generated
for this particular line of code.
So here,
the basic rule of thumb generally GPT
models follow is 1 token is around
approximately 4 characters or 70% of
natural English, right? But when
It comes to code, right?
It relies more on.
The code relies more on indentation.
We have a lot of special characters,
and we include a lot of non-standard
naming conventions,
which often consume significantly more
tokens per character than the plain text.
So there is an overhead which is coming
in.
Right,
so how do how so this is what is the
tokenization which happens?
Right,
so every time calculate sum is not
treated as one token.
which is a problem for us, right?
So first we need to understand how models
see the code. Humans,
we read the codes semantically, right?
We say function name means,
function under score name means,
we know that the function is given a name
and it does something.
But the tokenizer breaks the text down
using statistical patterns based on its
training vocabulary.
So common words will come under a single
token, like function, class, input,
return,
all that will come under a single token.
But our custom identifiers will often be
split into multiple words, sorry,
multiple tokens. So custom variable,
like this is how most of our variables
will look like, right?
something with the camel case and with a
complex.
This is how our variables are defined in
general. So such variables.
when we are having a custom identifier
created.
The tokenizer will split it into multiple
subwords, get user payment history,
4 subwords.
Four tokens will be generated for one
custom variable,
which will not solve our purpose of a
custom variable.
And there will be a lot of get user
payment history,
at least does not have an under score or
something,
but generally we have this identifiers
where we have environmental variables or
other identifiers.
So there we will have a lot of
underscores.
etc. So compressed names, say for example,
user under score ENB,
we have a lot of environmental variables,
like ENB slash dev,
something like that we'll have.
So these kind of identifiers,
they will be split into.
user,
then one under score will be separate
token, then the E&
V will be separate token,
or even EN can be separate and V can be
also separate.
So many tokens will be created.
So, when a variable, basic variable,
which has to be treated as a single token,
is split into six tokens,
the model has to spend.
more processing power and context space
just to track that single variable's
identity.
So this is going to cause us problems.
Because models operate on subword IDs
rather than raw text, tokenization
Creates multiple.
Failure modes during the code generation
and analysis,
so these are some problems which are
induced.
When a model sees the code, OK,
so I will explain few problems, OK,
and then basic things,
not very detailed ones.
What are the general pitfalls on?
in languages like Python and YAML.
Deep inundation.
is required. There will be many spaces,
many tabs.
So those will consume tokens rapidly.
So there will be a bloat in the number of
tokens.
And in JavaScript, if you see,
when we pass,
generally when we write code for the
front end,
in some of you who have worked with the
app or any any kind of front end
frameworks,
you will know that how the code is
minified, right? All the entire code will.
will go through a minification,
so there will be a webpack or something.
which will construct the code into a
continuous long string into a set of
minified JavaScript and send it to the
first front end to the browser or
something, right?
So passing minified JavaScript will cause
the tokenizer to break long
continuous strings into dozens of tiny,
inefficient tokens,
which drives up the cost and it will
degrade the reasoning power of the model.
So that is one kind of a problem.
And so I'm just listing down the possible
problems,
what will happen when model sees the code
in a subword pattern.
So 2 problems I told you,
one is the intonation bloat,
other is the minified code example.
Um...
And then when building a.
pipelines,
programmatic pipelines that need to work
on strings and characters, right?
There can be those which can be split
into a multi-token, into half, etc. So...
A API structure, right?
It API structure has to be intact, right?
Otherwise,
so when I say HTTP colon slash slash
example.
dot ONG.
Slash user.
slash one,
the entire thing only will work.
If I remove part of it or remove part of
it, it will not work, right?
So sometimes when they truncate raw
string character lengths directly,
they can split them into multiple tokens
in half, pausing.
Downstream API syntax errors.
Good.
And, uh, what happened then?
All right.
I think that was my mistake.
So this can cause.
Some problems, right? So,
the splitting itself can cause some
problems, and one...
String manipulation problem is LLMs,
if you look at the basic LLMs,
today LLMs are powerful,
or they have changed,
or they have been re-engineered in terms
of how they tokenize code.
But LLMs generally struggle to reverse
strings or count characters accurately.
Okay, you would have seen some,
I some time back if you would have tried.
I don't know if still that error occurs,
but if you ask how many E is there in a
word, right?
It is most likely that it will tell it
incorrect.
Okay,
but I don't know still if that exists,
but generally it was the case.
So it struggles with identifying or
counting characters accurately because
they never get to see individual
characters. They see only tokens.
They don't even see tokens.
They only see the token IDs.
Right, so this is what they the LLMC,
the token IDs.
Okay,
so they don't even see the token itself.
So it's very hard for them to calculate
count characters or reverse strings, etc.
They see token IDs which represents the
chunk of text. So if you ask the LLM to...
A slicer string or reverse a string,
or show me the character at index 14,
it will not give you the right answer.
It often fails because the token.
Boundaries don't align with the character
indexes.
So that is 1 problem.
These are all token induced failure modes
in code when the model is trying to read
through the data. So indentation,
white space drift, every white space tab,
everything is seen as tokens.
So it can lead to long.
And it can also even lead to some
prediction errors.
Then special characters. So for example,
symbols like parentheses, curly braces,
all that,
they don't always pair neatly into tokens
with the neighboring text. For example,
here, at least in this example,
These together pad together.
Of course, it looks like a sad smiley.
I don't know if that is the what the
meaning the.
LLM info,
but generally they don't very well.
gel with the next token or they don't
always pair neatly with the neighboring
token,
which will again inflate the content
consumption if they are to be treated as
separate ones.
And especially when it comes to C or
dense syntax based languages,
it becomes more.
problematic for us.
So now I have told you a list of problems,
but did any of you face these problems
while actually using the code LLMs in
your work?
Did any of you experience this at all?
So, Guru RAJ says no. Okay,
Sirisha says no. So, no, okay,
Abhinav says, Mridul says yes. So,
which problem, Mridul, did you experience?
I mean, today, recently, I'm asking.
Right,
so all the codes which we are working
with and all our cloud code or GitHub
Copilot,
which uses multiple models in the backend,
we don't face these issues.
I'm telling you these issues and you are
looking at me as if I'm talking something
which does not exist, right?
So the reason...
You rarely encounter all these
tokenization issues in modern LLM is.
You don't encounter them or you rarely
encounter them because the labs,
the research has spent the last few years
on how tokenizers should work.
And a lot of re-engineering has gone into
the tokenizers itself.
Okay,
so the re-engineered tokenizers is what
we are actually using in the real-time
models or what is running in the back end
of our models today.
So that is why none of the problem which
I told you exists in real-time today,
but it was a problem a few years back or
when the initial versions of
LLM bag used, right? So the research.
has spent the last few years
re-engineering tokenizers,
also looking at the model architectures
and training pipelines specifically to
neutralize them.
While the underlying mechanism,
that is the subword tokenization,
is still present,
there has been several key innovations
made on top of them to hide these kind of
problems which commonly was faced by the
coding community or understanding code
from the.
Yes.
Okay, so let's understand,
let's spend some time to understand what
kind of re-engineering did they do.
Yeah.
Okay, says not recently, right?
That's true. Maybe a few years back,
we would have, I think,
the number that occurrence of character
or reversing a string was a problem in
the early versions of GPT.
I think it was not possible to do that at
all, right? The code doesn't compile or...
whatever code it gives,
it has errors or syntax mistakes,
or the way it understands the code itself
will be different, right?
So that is how it actually was.
Common errors were based on string
manipulations,
character identifying characters.
This minification was a bigger problem in
JavaScript.
Then this strong syntax languages, not C,
etc. They had a lot of problems.
etc.
So what are the re-engineering which was
done?
The old tokenizers,
what they didn't have is the
understanding of a code.
They treated code like English language,
causing white spaces and symbols to
fragment in a very awkward way,
which doesn't suit the code semantics or
the syntax.
of the language, programming language.
But modern models, the GPT-4, the Claude,
Lama, all that,
they built a purpose-based tokenizer,
that is tokenizers explicitly for code
structures, which can understand the code,
the structure of the code, how
code is created, how code is structured,
the semantics and the syntax of it.
So tokenizers now include individual
tokens representing specific length of
white spaces. So one space, two space,
all these are tokens.
So if you have 8 spaces or different
indent levels, they have specific,
they represent the
as a specific word or a token.
So if you have Python intents to be
generated as a single token rather than
multiple guest tokens,
you can easily do that by eliminating the
white space drift.
etc.
And modern byte pair encoding algorithms,
what they do is they map unknown or rare
character sequences directly to raw bytes.
So this what will happen,
unknown character sequences or rare
character in the sense all our special
characters, mathematical operations,
special brackets, all the special syntax,
they map to single consistent tokens
rather than they randomly getting
fragmented across different places at
different contexts.
Like whenever they see something,
out of the text or a rare character
sequence,
they immediately make them as individual
character tokens.
So,
rather than fragmenting them incorrectly,
so those kind of simple re-engineering
was done in tokenizers,
and in the early models.
They only saw token positions,
but they didn't see how many characters
were present inside each token.
So token one position and token 2
position,
that is what the semantic distance
between them was calculated to identify
how probabilistically near they are, etc.
Say, they saw the token positions,
but how many characters were inside each
token? That kind of...
check they didn't have at all.
So the modern LLMs or modern tokenizers,
they incorporate positional metadata that
can have a token index and precise
character offsets also.
So this was possible to work with strings,
characters,
all that string manipulations on it.
And also yesterday I told about chain of
thought prompting and internal scratch
pads, right?
So when you ask the modern model to slice
a string at, say,
index 14 or reverse a string, whatever,
the earlier steps,
earlier problems I told you,
which will not work.
right?
Models are trained to do the thinking,
then it has to give us a step-by-step
reasoning and the internal scratch pad it
will,
and then gives us the scratch pad itself,
right?
So by breaking down the token into
characters step by step,
the model will bypass the tokenization
bottleneck.
So,
there will start when it starts to
reasoning,
we saw that it improved the understanding
of strings.
etc.
So the reasoning models worked well with
reversing a string or identifying the
character at this index position, etc.
Because they had a step of reasoning and
they had the context which step by step
calculations, etc.
So that was also one of the re-engineered
steps in the tokenizers,
which works well with code base, etc.
And the last one.
is training them,
training them on our compiler based data,
that is abstract syntax tree,
syntax guided pre-training. So during,
our models are now explicitly fine-tuned
on synthetic data sets designed to teach
them
the internal structure of their own
vocabulary. So the fine-tuning steps.
incorporate them,
incorporate this syntax training.
So during the training phase,
models are trained on tasks like breaking
the token into individual characters or
count the occurrences of the letter E in
the word explicitly.
by reasoning step-by-step logic.
So when such token decomposition tasks
are fine-tuned and they are trained
internally,
then it also improves the tokenization
techniques. Plus,
you train the data on the abstract syntax
trees.
the linter feedbacks or how your syntax
log should look like and how the
structure of your code should look like,
et cetera.
So that kind of a training was given the
initial added to the vocabulary of the
models,
which in turn reduced all our problems
which we are facing with the.
data. Okay, so again,
still I would not say the problem is
completely gone.
We still have problems because they are
majorly for text and that is where we
have a lot of engineering to come inside
and improvements to come inside.
So I will talk about
two options,
how that interventions we can bring into
the model or we can be adding to the
model shortly. But before that,
let's look at the example itself.
So, in this example, if you see...
That is, this is the piece of code.
OK.
And you can see that the old model will
process it like a text.
So, process data will be treated,
process under score data will be treated
as separate,
item ID will be treated as separate,
and now...
In the new model,
you can see it has a little more semantic
meaning. The tokens are better organized,
suitable for a code. OK, now let's,
I want...
some of you to try this in this. Also,
I'm just pasting this,
or you can also take any other code also.
But let's all of us try one single code
so we can identify the difference.
It's statement.
So I have 16 tokens in llama.
And Naveen.
In GPT, earlier GPT, I am having...
16 tokens.
T.P.T. 3:30, okay.
I think none of these models which are
given in our examples are re-engineered
for code, I think. They might not have,
they might be basic models.
Right,
I don't see any model which is treating
item under score ID as the same.
Right,
did any of you get something like that
item ID,
something similar to the new model output
which we are seeing on the screen?
Like item and ID is treated as one
variable.
He might not get it as I guess I think,
but these models which are there in the
tokenizer might be basic ones,
they might not be engineered or code
enough.
Okay.
Right, so...
Let's take a quick break here,
5 minutes break.
Right, and...
I will talk about a few additional
changes, tokenization can be done,
or how we can cope up such problems with
the model, system level interventions,
and then I will go to context window.
And that we will end for today.
So let's take a break and come back.
Five minutes break.
Okay, so let us continue.
So, the new models, actually,
they understand the code-based models,
they understand. So, I think GPT-4,
Claude latest versions and all,
they understand it.
Maybe we can use some libraries.
There are some tokenized libraries or
there are some endpoints.
Maybe we can use some of them and check
how it,
the number of tokens and how it actually
divides later.
So now I am more inclined.
This is a little off topic only,
I would say,
but I felt that this is very important to
be discussed.
In terms of re-engineering,
because the reason why you don't
encounter the issues which really which
are related to code is also because a
certain system level interventions we are
having,
especially when we are using Copilot or
agent code or something like that in our.
To process our files,
we are not having many problems or their
work much better than the previous time,
is because...
Whenever there is a complex stream
manipulation or there is a.
index calculation,
which is very difficult in a
probabilistic system to be done,
but very simple in a deterministic line
of code.
So if I want to just reverse a string,
it's very simple in Python or any
language, right?
It's just four or five lines of code.
Or even if I have a library,
then it's just one line of code.
But that is very difficult for a...
yell them to do that.
Right, so...
What?
This basically does this.
There are some delegations which are
happening.
When models need to manipulate strings
precisely, advanced models,
or if they have been,
I don't say by default they will do this,
okay?
So that's a caution, I think. By default,
it doesn't happen,
but they can be trained or they can be
configured.
To manipulate strings precisely,
they can invoke external Python
interpreters or deterministic linters to
run the operation and give you the exact
output.
instead of them probabilistically
guessing something, they can do that,
right? So even with better tokenizers.
You ask a neural network to calculate
letter indexes,
correct character positioning,
or if you enforce strict syntax rules
using...
It is very difficult for them to do that
because they are basically probabilistic
guesswork, right?
So it is like asking humans to do a
complex mental math,
though many of them might do it correctly,
but it is prone to silly errors at some
place if it's a complex math.
We might miss out on when we are dealing,
for example, matrix multiplication. Say,
I'm giving you a 25 cross 25 matrix.
and I ask you to do it,
you'll be able to do it.
We know the process,
but there is a fatigue and there is a
possibility, a silly error we might make,
right? So even with better tokenization,
asking a neural network or a LLM based
out of transformers to calculate letter
indexes.
or enforce strict syntax rules,
using probabilistic guessing is not the
right thing to do.
So system level interventions,
what they do is they don't try to make
the neural network better at character
counting. Instead, they build.
or they allow a safety harness,
access to a deterministic tool around the
model that the model can go and delegate
the exact work and forces and this back
to the output.
So this is very important for us.
And this gives us a very important lesson
for us. It's not necessary.
We shouldn't be asking.
We have well-tested ways of so many years
of software engineering to reverse a
string,
and we know how it can be done in better
ways, covering all edge cases.
etc, right?
So why would we have to go in for a
probabilistic approach to that particular
step if it is not going to be good at it?
It is still there are high chances that
there will be a mistake, right?
So in that case comes the delegation.
You delegate the task.
Instead of forcing the model to do the
character level manipulation and guess
the result, you know, if you run a code,
you are going to get the right
deterministic result, right?
So the system allows the model to write a
code.
To solve that problem, say, for example,
I want to find out V.
reverse of a string,
or I want to divide the string at a given
character index 14, right?
Instead of asking the model to guess what
will be the character,
I ask the model will write a code to
solve it,
run the code in an isolated environment,
and read the answer or give the answer.
If you ask an LLM to do it to reverse a
string or do me the character at index 14,
the raw model will try to do a
statistical pattern matching over the
subword tokens,
and because it sees tokens rather than
raw characters, it can go.
and make the errors or hallucinate the
output.
So now when tool intervention solves it,
what tool intervention will do is most
modern systems like ChatGPT data analysis
or plot code with code execution, etc.
They route the task through an internal
execution loop. So first,
it goes back to the reasoning.
So when a user request comes in,
say my request is reverse the string and
give me the character at index 14. Okay,
I remember the input, okay, I'm repeating.
Reverse the string, OK,
and then give me the character at index
14 - that's the input I'm giving,
so the model will first try to identify
the task.
and it understands,
it goes through a reasoning, right?
So it doesn't go to system one thinking
immediately, try to find out the answer.
It goes to a reasoning.
It identifies that the task which needs
to be done here is string manipulation.
So LLM will generate the Python code
internally.
And then there will be a system sandbox
or a Python interpreter,
which will be the system access will be
given, which will execute that code.
And LLM will receive the deterministic
execution result and answer the user.
So here it is switching from guessing to
executing.
And the some word tokenization
limitations are entirely bypassed.
So this is a very, I mean, for me,
it looked like a more sensible and a more
intuitive way of doing things, right?
That's how we should be doing it.
And this is what is the models today are
capable of doing.
Right, so.
I will come back,
go back to this previous one.
So an old tokenizer processes a typical
snippet of Python code in a different way.
It treats this as a national, sorry,
natural English language.
And when faced with codes,
they struggle with a lot of problems,
white space, all that I told you.
Even with an improvised tokenizer,
which is structured and efficient,
they use a expanded vocabulary.
So what do I mean by a new model or an
improvised re-engineered tokenizer is
they are trained on code.
They are given the abstract AST,
that is the abstract syntax tree.
So they have an expanded vocabulary.
with the explicit white space pattern,
common multi-character of programming
operators, all that. So with that,
certain problems are overcome. That is,
indents, which are atomic single steps,
are clumped together.
So new line or 8 space, 4 space,
all of them are combined together.
the entire variable can be treated as a
single token.
It will reduce character slicing errors,
right? And common structural pairs,
like the braces,
are merged into single tokens,
reducing the context bloat, et cetera,
right?
So even though all this is happening,
The process data is singles.
Single token,
the model learns where character lies.
Though the process data will be taken as
a single token or item ID is taken as a
single token.
The token ID is what will be passed to
the model.
So the model learns where character lies
only through character-aware embedding
layers and more fine-tuning.
Okay,
so did this process say if this is the
process data or this is 1 token, okay,
but this is 1 token and I asked what is
the character in the?
second index, et cetera,
it should know the character of sets,
plus it should maintain a character level
information. Otherwise,
it will not be able to answer that.
So when you ask the modern model to slice
a variable or count characters,
its internal attention heads
should be able to explicitly map the
subword token,
and then it should have maintained the
character embedding positions in a high
dimensional vector space,
and then only it will be able to answer
that question. That is,
a smarter way is to go for
Such a system level.
interventions where you don't try to make
them count, right?
So first is a code interpreter and other
latching tools where you are delegating
the task. The second step,
or it's also a system level intervention,
but it's a different way.
What you do there, you in the first one,
the code interpreters, you are
Switching from guessing to executing.
And the limitation of a subword
tokenization is entirely bypassed.
Whereas here, when an LLM generates code,
or say a JSON file,
it normally produces a list of
probabilities, right?
So all these are called as logits.
That is the possible for every possible
token in its vocabulary.
and it will pick the one which has the
most likely one.
OK, so now.
Sometimes,
the most likely one might be a syntax
error.
Or it might be using a different
selection,
which is not even suitable for that
particular probability.
So when I'm asking LLM to generate a code,
right,
model calculates probabilities of the
next token and gives me the next one.
But in that probability list,
there might be many things which comes
under invalid syntax.
Right, for example, say...
Let's take and...
Example.
Say, I'm having a function.
OK, so I say function,
and then I give a name to it.
OK, and then there should be parentheses.
This is what is should come next, right?
So, token A, the first guessing.
The first guessing might be something
else. Next to name,
it might guess something else.
Say there is a 90 probability or then it
says function again.
So there is some 90 probability and then
for the...
parentheses,
there is only an 8% probability.
Right, so see, there are.
Four possibilities. OK,
let's take a simple example.
The next token to come after this
parenthesis has 8%,
function keyword has 80%,
and say there is a name, some name,
random name like John.
It has 90%.
Something like this, OK?
Out of these four,
maybe 50% or more than 50% is invalid
syntax, right?
So why should a language model spend time
which is incorrect on the syntax?
Because it doesn't know the syntax
constraints or the enforcement of the...
syntax at all.
So model just calculates probability of
the next token and it will select some
one with the highest probability,
but it might be an invalid syntax,
then it has to re-correct it, etc.
So what we will do there is to apply a
constraint.
Right,
we evaluate first among all the next
token, we will categorize, okay,
this is incorrect, this is incorrect,
only two of them are possibilities.
Then it can pick one from that.
So it first evaluates all the
possibilities based on the grammar.
the abstract syntax tree or Python
indentation.
And then it forcibly sets the
probabilities of the incorrect syntax to
0%. So these probabilities will go to 0%.
So automatically they will not be picked.
So the engine enforces
the most probable one among the valid
syntax to be predicted next.
So this is one way of enforcing or giving
a system level intervention,
that is system level engines,
which are used to run
the LLMs.
So we are not getting technically there
as BLLMs,
then there are some JSON mode APIs, etc.
They can maintain a context-free grammar
or a syntax tree in the background which
will do this work.
It will remove all the incorrect.
probability tokens and make their
probabilities to 0 so that before the
model even picks up the next token,
the engine checks which tokens are
legally allowed by the grammar rules and
any token that would violate.
the syntax rule that is an unintended
line inside an if block or a missing code
in James.
And all these are unintended invalid
tokens is masked out completely by
setting a probability to 0.
And because these illegal tokens or
invalid syntax tokens, whatever is there,
are physically blocked from being.
outputted,
we'll have very less syntax errors,
missing brackets,
or white space problems will become
impossible. So this is 1 level.
You're not completely relying on the
model.
You are adding an extra constraint
guarding the syntax.
by additional external support.
So this is what actually we have to do.
Of course,
the Cloud Code and GitHub Copilot and the
Gravity, all of them are doing this.
Right,
but we have to also have an understanding
and tomorrow we might be writing our own
guardrails and own system level
interventions based on which we can
restrict them.
So this way we will be able to
re-engineer how the models work and
improve them or reduce the dependency on
them.
Development such kind of comment.
And us.
Right.
So now we transition or we move to the
context window. Now we have talked,
spoke enough about tokens.
Now we have to go and get into the.
context. What is a context window?
It is a working memory.
In very short term,
LLM's context window is its working
memory;
it represents the maximum amount of
information a model can read, process,
and keep in mind at a single point in
time during a conversation.
So what is the relationship between
tokens and context window?
Tokens are the unit of measurement for
the context window.
How do I measure a context window, right?
In real time, how do I measure a window?
I say by length, meters and centimeters,
right?
So a context window is measured in terms
of token,
how much capacity a context window is at.
is measured by a token.
So just as digital storage can be
measured by bytes, megabytes,
LLM's context window is measured in terms
of tokens.
Every model we have will have an upper
limit to the maximum number of tokens.
When I say maximum number of tokens,
it includes the input prompt as well as
the number of tokens in the output from
the model. So it will have a limit.
So that is what is the context.
window is about.
Now what are the things which will be
counted in the context window?
Right.
Everything in the request plus everything
in the response.
Every piece of data passed to or
generated by the LLM is converted into
hot tokens, system prompt,
custom instructions, conversation history,
which needs your past messages, models,
past answer.
Current user.
prompt response.
The context window is the limit on the
combined sum of all these items.
So a token limit when I say it is the
hard ceiling on the total number of AI
tokens a large language model can process
in a single inference column.
which includes the input prompt,
the context, the documents you pass,
the retrieved documents,
the conversation history,
the model's own output.
All this combined together,
that is the token limit.
So the maximum context length.
And then the total token count of
or request reaches the model's limit.
The model cannot process any additional
context.
The content that exceeds the limit must
either is truncated or it is summarized
or it is split across multiple calls.
So token limits are the fundamental
architectural constraint that we have to
work with to directly shape or design how
AI applications have to be built or
designed and how they have to behave in.
So it's a architectural constraint we
have to work with.
We should know what are the limitations.
And we have to, of course,
anytime we have to design with
constraints, right?
So earlier we were looking at only GBs
and RAM size and we were looking at only
other factors.
So now we have to look at one additional
factor also, which is the token limit.
And when we design AI systems,
we have to consider this limit and then
only design our.
Systems.
So a computer has 1 GB RAM. Similarly,
a given AI LLM model has 1024 token as
its context window.
This 1 GB RAM is fixed, right?
It's not 1024 tokens. It's not.
fixed. It is for that one inference call,
the maximum number of tokens it can
handle is that. So for example,
if you look at major models,
if you take Google Gemini series,
1 million to 2 million tokens are
designed today, the Gemini 3.56.
So they can handle up.
To one 1,000,000 to 2 million tokens,
right? And Claude starts from 200,
000 tokens to 1,000,
000 tokens on the based on the tier
different flagship tiers they have, right?
They have different CDs and...
So that's how it is.
So when I say token limit,
it is the ceiling.
So GPT models,
they have something around 12,000. Sorry,
not 12,000.
It's all good.
Something near to Claude only,
so they have some 120,
100 something like that,
so they have they support so many tokens
in a single inference spot. So,
when I say single inference,
they include the input, the output.
Also.
Right, so how does this token limit works,
right?
Most of the time you face, okay,
MADHURI says most of the time you face
context limit exceeded in copilot, right?
So first suggestion when we give is you
have to break down your problem into
smaller problems.
Okay, use a tokenizer. See how many,
your input prompt,
how many tokens it is taking. Also,
there are many other things,
not only the prompt, right?
All the things you see on the screen,
conversation history, the system prompt,
some will have system prompts,
then the response,
everything together is the context window.
So that's why we have 1 million,
2 million tokens allowed.
context window limits.
So you please see how it works.
You try to divide your task into smaller
tasks.
Don't allow it to work with multiple
files. Go one by one.
and see how it works.
Right,
so how actually what happens when token
limits are reached or why it matters,
right?
We'll spend some more time understanding
it.
Say, for example.
Token limits are enforced at the
transformer attention layers,
that is the self-attention mechanism.
So because, as I told you yesterday,
the large language models of the
transformers, they
And the capability to relate to other
tokens, understand the other tokens,
et cetera, right?
So they had the option to relate to every
other token within the sequence length,
and they had the long context,
and they made it possible. So providers,
when they set a token limit,
they set it at the attention layer to
balance
Why do they set it?
What will happen if they don't set it is?
There might be problems in inference cost,
latency, the quality, the model,
the output,
because it is referring to a lot of
probabilistic information, the embeddings,
and then only it's calculating the next
word, et cetera.
So it might not give you correct output,
it might give you incorrect output.
So that's why the limit is set.
So the quality, inference cost, latency,
all these are factors which are
considered and the token limit is set,
right?
So when you exceed that particular token
limit,
what will happen when we exceed a token
limit in an API call?
We used to have limits in APIs also,
right? Cloud-based APIs,
external third-party APIs, right?
We will just get a 404 error, right?
So similar kind of a thing,
the context window consumed by a single
request includes all this information.
So engineers have to 1st typically alert.
will be available for the conversation
history retrieved documents on this.
OK, so we have to.
I messed up, okay, sorry.
Okay, when? Am I audible now? Okay.
When was I stuck?
Okay, it's just solved now. Okay, great.
Okay, I'll repeat the last part. Okay,
I was saying about how the token limits
work, right?
So say I'll just repeat the last two,
3 minutes again.
So I was talking about how tokens work.
So the token limit is set on the...
self-attention layers in the transformers.
So the providers, why do they set it?
To ensure that the model gives quality
output,
the cost is under control and it doesn't
have high latency.
So there are various reasons what they
consider and set that context window
limit, the token limit.
Now, in practical terms,
the context window includes not only the
input prompt,
but it also includes system prompts,
documents from your context,
retrieved documents, conversation history,
output, everything.
So if I say my input prompt is 2000
tokens,
and I'm reserving some 5,
000 tokens for the output.
So the remaining,
say if I have my context window size is
100,000, the remaining 94 and 93,
000 is whatever is available for the
conversation history and retrieve
documents. If they are within that,
it will work well.
Right, and why this token limits matter,
right? What will happen if you exceed it,
right?
The cost factor is what is very important.
Most LLM APIs, they charge us on the...
per token consumed basis.
So a longer context means higher cost per
call. So in GPT-4,
rupees 5 or $5 per million tokens is what
is given.
If that is the case,
then you can see how much your cost will
be, right?
So that's why you have a daily limit,
right?
So when you have a complex analysis task
or when you have a high volume customer
support interaction.
where the same model might be called
multiple times,
then there will be problems.
So that is why the token limits matter a
lot. Not only on the cost factor,
you also have to understand the latency.
Processing a larger context means it
takes longer time.
So the time to first token scales with
the input length.
Right, so 100,
000 token prompt will had considerably
had at least 2 to 200 to 500 milliseconds
of processing time.
Right, so cost, latency,
as well as accuracy.
Accuracy is something which we didn't
discuss much, but research has,
there is a lot of research which shows
that LLMs are most accurate when you...
start the conversation that is beginning
of and the end of a long context.
In the middle,
there is always lost in the middle
problem.
Okay,
information buried in the middle of a
large context window is retrieved very
less and there is very less reliability
on that information.
So that problem is still there.
So accuracy is also a problem.
So very large contexts do not always
improve accuracy.
They can introduce noise or irrelevant
material will fill the window.
So there are some problems related to
that.
So token limit and context window,
they are used interchangeably in many
places,
but there is a very subtle distinction.
The context window is the span of tokens
a model can attend at one inference time.
It's active working memory.
The token limit is the number bound on
the window. OK,
so that is how it works with.
Right, so common problems we face when...
The model token limits are.
reached is the silent degradation.
It stops giving you the output which is
expected.
So that is one of the most common
problems.
The second is the attention dilution
which I was telling about.
So it doesn't give you the...
How's it going?
It doesn't give you information about
what was discussed in the middle.
Some information gets lost in the middle.
And then we also have problems.
And.
Model gives us inconsistent outputs,
or there might be cascading failures,
especially when you have agents running
in, it lost context,
it might skip validation,
or the context windows reached,
it might skip validation and go to the
next step,
or it might leave out certain files.
in order to save the context window,
all that.
So those kind of inconsistent behavior
and failures is what we will face.
Right,
so the basic take away is there's nothing
new.
We will not build a web service without
monitoring the memory usage.
We will decide and then how we do the
scaling, right?
When we have to post our workloads on the
cloud and all, we have been monitoring.
We had our telementary system,
we had observability,
we monitored how much the...
web service will use, etc. Same way,
you don't build agents without tracking
the token conceptions. Right,
so that is what is expected.
So, I'll stop here for today.
some reading materials I will give of
which you can go through and
So, next class.
What we will discuss is on the...
We will start with prompt.
So so far we have been more confined to
the LLMs as such,
but we have to go a little above LLMs on
the agents, right?
So when it comes to agent,
the model is there,
but agent is equal to model plus and
harness around it.
We have to control it because it is going
to act autonomously.
So we have to understand that.
So we will look at agent as a workflow,
some agentic workflow, some examples.
And we will also look at prompt
strategies.
There is a little bit of prompt
engineering which we have to combine.
So that we'll look at.
and we will start.
We will start with the development of the
STLC cycle from contact session 7.
So that is should be the plan.
So, questions I will take up.
Yes.
This will be from tomorrow, as I told you.
So whatever is covered till today, CS5,
that will be the questions for the quiz.
So it will be starting from tomorrow and
it will run for a week.
So you can attend it anytime.
Eight.
How many modules we can expect as
syllabus for EC2?
You will see we are learning a little
late.
I think I will be able to.
Just give me a second, I mean.
Opening the handout.
So, we are in Module Two,
and we have one more class of Module Two.
and requirements and design.
We will have,
and maybe we will start on coding.
So, for...
Four or 3.4 half of four.
Right, so that that is what we will have,
right? And how many questions?
There will be 20 questions and 30 minutes.
for the quiz. You can attend it anytime,
but once you open,
you have to finish it within 30 minutes.
Right,
so assignment we will start a little
later after,
we will not start immediately.
Conversational prompts,
will they use more token than the one
clear prompt? Yes, that's right. They,
because they have extra words, right?
Even your...
interrogative verbs like who, what, etc.
They all consume extra words, right?
So sometimes the models itself,
sure I can answer this,
they will waste some tokens in that by
giving you some, you are right,
some kind of introductory statements, etc.
So.
Conversational prompts, obviously, yes,
they will use more tokens than one clear
prompt.
That's true.
So we'll have something on prompt
engineering in next class,
so we can discuss a little bit in detail.
Right,
so all PPT and content I will add to
Teams and the e-learn page immediately
after the session.
And any other questions,
please let me know.
Yeah, question paper,
give me some three four days time.
Yeah, listen.
So by next week,
I'll give you a rough probable quest idea
so that you can have some inputs on the
questions.
Yeah, good evening ma'am.
So I'm about to ask the same like for
easy to how we can prepare like an idea.
So stick to the slides and the topics you
can stick to the slides.
Yeah.
The references is something you can
explore further.
Yeah.
For the module 2 AI engineering book,
which is from,
which is listed in your handout also,
reference to that would be the more
suitable book.
And I have been adding all the references
in one of the pages in TEAMS, right?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
So you can use that as a pointer to
prepare.
Yeah, the reason is like,
as per the topic,
it's not in one single textbook or
something correct.
Thanks.
So it will be like tough for us.
So that's the reason we just asked and
like,
I think this is the first subject
introduced in this year, I think.
Previous bits, AI Augmented,
it is not there.
It's not that big.
Yeah, so that is the reason like,
you know,
we don't know like how to prepare for the
exam as you we already aware that is
closed book system and we know we can't
see anything in right correct.
So that is the reason in order to attempt
well,
that is the reason I just asked ma'am.
Sure, okay.
And a general instruction I would like to
pass on to everyone is irrespective of
open book or closed loop.
The questions for this course will mostly
be scenario based. So it is not,
it will not be something where you have
to remember a lot of things.
OK, always our questions are.
As far as my courses are concerned,
it will be scenario based. You will apply,
you have to go through the concepts.
It will be very less of remembering and
recall, and it will be more of applying.
So once you have an understanding of the
flow, the software engineering concepts,
as well as the...
different types of models, etc.
Given a scenario of what answer fits well
or what is your justification.
So questions also will be related to that.
So that's how the entire WILP exams have
to be.
So you don't have to worry much about
remembering things.
Okay, ma'am, thank you for clarifying.
Don't mind for asking.
So it's a first subject in this.
No, no, that's fine.
This is a very common question.
You don't have to feel bad.
So especially if I contact session five
Yeah.
process,
then there is a lot of questions on the
exams.
Though we say that marks are mere numbers,
but still that's our Indian system of
education. We are focused on marks, right?
Is this?
So that's okay. That's completely fine.
Yeah, so as you said,
like any rough way of like it will we
Okay.
will be sharing right just for like a
sure.
Yes,
I will share a I will share a sample kind
of questions,
so you get an idea on how it will.
Shoot.
Yeah, yeah. Thank you so much, ma'am.
Yeah, thank you.